another blade runner sequel and ridley
scott is signed on
welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
blade runner 2099 looks like it's in the
works deadline is reporting that this is
in the early stages of production and it
will be on amazon prime amazon according
to deadline
really are prioritizing this tv show i
wanted to get it into filming as quickly
as possible this is going to be a
massive project and ridley scott is
signed on he may even direct
so this will not be a reboot it will not
even really be a soft reboot it will be
a continuation of the existing story so
we have the original blade runner movie
and then blade runner 2049 this is
obviously going to be set 50 years after
that the hint is in the title blade
runner 2099 it's been reported that
alcon the production company behind tv
series like the expanse is going to make
in this tv series in cooperation with uh
scot-free productions even though ridley
scott actually decided to step back from
directing uh blade runner 2049
apparently according to deadline he is
very keen to direct this television
series and he wants it to be absolutely
perfect
amazon are planning a big investment in
the series
like they're investing in everything
else to try and keep themselves ahead of
the streaming wars and silk lisa is
coming out as a writer and executive
producer
now this is still all a little bit rumor
nothing is dead unofficial but to be
honest for me there are too many details
for this for there not to be something
in it i think this is probably going to
be officially announced very very
shortly and ridley scott i am absolutely
certain will be directing and very much
involved in making sure this series is
the best it can possibly be
guys what do you think get in the
comments is this a tv project that
you're looking forward to do you think
there is enough to this universe that we
could see something really exciting
personally i do but leave me a comment
and tell me what you think also if you
are new to the channel please like
subscribe hit the bell notification it
really helps us out and you can become a
fully fledged side tracker hit the join
button below as always guys please stay
safe and i'll see